hello guys this is Luxur from simply
lund and welcome to this tutorial on
Java and capsulation this is a part of a
Java tutorial series where we will cover
everything you need to know to master
Java now without wasting any time let's
move on to our topic
let's see the definition of
encapsulation encapsulation is like a
capsule the whole code and data is
bounded together into a single unit
another way to think about encapsulation
is it is a protective shield that
prevents the data from being accessed by
the code outside this shield as you can
see variables and methods are defined
inside one class like a capsule now the
question is why do we need encapsulation
the main reasons are first
better control of class attributes and
methods second class attributes can be
made read-only or write-only third it
makes Java code very flexible
this means the programmer can change one
part of the code without affecting other
parts apart from these and capsulation
is mainly used to protect data and
increase security of the code as you can
see to protect the data variables must
be private and they can only be accessed
through methods now let's see Java code
for encapsulation to understand the
concept better so now let's create a new
project
next
next and I'm gonna name it as and cap
one
so here we have a main class we can
write the code here so before I take the
code let me create a new class right
click new Java class and I am going to
name it as employee so in this program
we are going to use a classic example of
employee using employee name ID and
salary so in this class let me create
variables
first string name
then integer ID and then in salary
so I can easily use these variables in
our main program by creating object of
the class so let me just create the
object employee is equal to new employee
now I can use a dot ID name or salary
anything I need to but this program is
about
encapsulation so this is an easy program
we can do but in order to secure our
programs when we have a large number of
program and large number of lines in a
program so we need encapsulation at that
time so that data can be secured so for
that I'm gonna name it as private
now all three variables are private so I
can't use them see we can't see them
anymore if I write ie D will get a red
color here so if we go on it we can see
ID has private access so that means we
can't use it directly because of this we
need getters and setters that are
normally methods that are used for these
so right click generate and here you can
see getters and setters so just select
all of them and ok so now we can use
these methods instead of direct using
the variables so we can get in the
starting then set then get and again set
so likewise it goes like this so now we
have set here so if I want to declare
variable and if I want to put some value
inside my variable so how can I do that
here you can see get ID or get salary so
if I go for get ID sorry if I go for a
dot set ID and I set it as 6 so this
shows no error this means we can use
methods to access variables so let's
complete our program now first I am
going to set everything
and lastly edad set celery let's get it
as 30,000 maybe in dollars or maybe in
rupees let's just set it as 30,000 for
now so how I'm gonna print it for this
I'm gonna go to a print statement and
then name
and II dot not set name but this time
I'm gonna go with get name get name is
to return the value of the name that I
have given so in this case that simply
learn and next will be ID and II dot get
ID
and lastly salary
II dot get salary so this is a simple
program that is used to define and
capsulation we don't use private
variables that becomes a normal program
so when we use encapsulation we are
going to use private every time whenever
we declare variables so that it's secure
and no one can access the variables
directly so now let's run the program
and there we go we have a result we have
executed the program successfully and as
you can see named simply learn ID six
and salary is thirty thousand so I hope
you understood the concept of
encapsulation so the main concept of
encapsulation is all the variables can
be accessed through methods so for this
we use getters and setters that are
inbuilt functions for IntelliJ or
NetBeans or eclipse
so with this let's move on to our next
program to understand it better and how
we can manipulate these variables or
methods using program so again let's
create a new project
and this time I'm gonna name it as
encapsulation - because it's the second
program for encapsulation and here we
have a main program now this time I'm
going to use an example of cars so let
me just create a new class and I'm going
to name it as cars so in this again I'm
going to create three variables that are
private
so first I'm gonna get string name then
private string price that means price of
the car and third one top speed of the
car
so we can create the program that we did
before as it is but I'm going to explain
you more in depth how we can manipulate
these variables or classes so I'm going
to create a constructor for the class
cause
and inside I'm gonna give it as
arguments a string name then string
price and string top speed
and I'm gonna give it as this dot name
is equal to name this is so that the
class can identify that we are going to
give arguments related to that and the
class can return the values of it so
similarly I am gonna give it as this dot
price is equal to price and lastly this
top speed is equal to top speed
so with this we have completed our
constructor for it now let's have
getters and setters for the same thing
for these three variables so generate
getter and setter select all and okay
this is a great feature that we have in
Java getters and setters otherwise we'll
have to type the whole code so with this
let's move on to our main program will
write the code here first I'll create
object of the class cars
and inside this I'm gonna give arguments
or inside this I'm gonna give values
that I use in constructor to assign the
values without using any C dot get name
or C dot get price so my first was name
so let me just name it as BMW the second
thing was price so I'm gonna give it as
$30,000 and the third one was top speed
so top speed I'm gonna give it as 200
kilometer per hour so we have assigned
all the values to the variables and we
have created object as well all in the
same line so this is another way of
creating objects or another way of
assigning values to the variables that
are private so if I try to print these
they can be easily printed
so in the starting name and CDOT so this
time I'm gonna give get name so it
automatically gets the value that I
assigned to the variables through
getters and setters
after that price
price seedot price cut price
and in the end
top speed
seedot get top speed so if I print this
that's executed
and there we go we have named BMW price
and even the top speed now if I give
spaces between them it will look neatly
so let me execute it once more and here
you go
name BMW price $30,000 and top speed 200
kilometer per hour so this is one of our
ways how we can declare variables or
assign values to the variables without
using any get a source at us so in this
method we used only get us to print the
value that we have for variables now how
can we manipulate the variables if we
want to change value of them now for
this again I can do set top speed or set
price let the name be as it is so C dot
set price so price I am going to set it
as
$50,000 and CDOT set top speed let me
increase it to 250 kilometer per hour
so before printing that I am so that we
can differentiate which one is new and
which one is old I am going to print one
more line stats after updation
so now if I print these values I'm just
going to copy paste it
so now if I print it let's execute it
and here you go first we have name price
and top speed then stats after updations
that means after we set the value the
value gets overwritten on the variables
and now we have a new price and top
speed and all the details so this is how
you can manipulate variables or values
inside the variables so this brings us
to the end of this video we learnt about
Java and capsulation I hope you liked
the video thanks for watching and stay
tuned for more from simply learn hi
there if you liked this video subscribe
to the simple learn YouTube channel and
click here to watch similar videos to
nerd up and get certified click here